the silence notorious for the number of
ships and planes that have gone missing
the 1954 nuclear test where our tests
they were trying to kill something
that's call King around here
it's time to show that man is king
run
Kong Skull Island rated pg-13
experienced it in IMAX March tens look
at that
Kohn's God on the island ancient species
owned this earth long before mankind
we're going to bring that tape down
we don't belong here we got a safe calm
Kong Skull Island rated pg-13 experience
it in IMAX March tens these are photos
of an island in the South Pacific the
place where myth and science meet we use
explosives to shake the earth helping us
to map the surface of the island you're
dropping bombs mmm
scientific instruments
is it a monkey
like ephah son
you knew that thing was out here I'm
sorry for your man colonel but if you
want to make the sacrifice worthwhile
get us home with proof monsters exist
whoa your friend there can put that down
what the hell is this place
that's calm he's King around here comes
pretty good King keeps himself mostly
well you don't go into someone's house
and start dropping bombs unless you're
picking a fight Cohen's God on the
island but the devil's live below us and
what if a calls I call skull crawlers
why never said that name out loud before
it sounds stupid now that I say just you
call him whatever you want
it's a good group of boys we're all
gonna die together out here come here
you came here looking for a tracker who
or what am i tracking that's the big one
before we leave this island we're going
to bring that eight down we're all gonna
die together out here haha he's a bit
coming here comes Carl and rated pg-13
experience at an IMAX March ends what
you're looking at is a monster from some
bygone ill from the cavalry I am the
cavalry
time to show that man is king
Civic over here come Skull Island
rated pg-13 experience it in IMAX March
chins it's a survey job just chopper
them in and out be a joyride
[Music]
[Music]
you are going to tell me everything I
don't know
I'm gonna blow your head off this planet
doesn't belong to us
[Music]
ancient species owned deserve long
before mankind I spent 30 years trying
to prove the truth
monster sixes
you don't go into someone's house unless
you're picking a fight
what you're looking at is a monster from
some bygone era
it's time to show Batman
is king
[Music]
minami tie a simple Shiva don't crew to
let a monkey Skoosh so cool Jin Lee
Puccini chichi
what the hell is this place you are
going to tell me everything I don't know
I'm gonna blow your head off
I spent 30 years trying to prove the
truth monsters exist
that's Kong he's King around here cones
God on the island but the Devils live
below us
Boosh module jin lee wan-koo skin uneasy
night
chinga conquer taught elocution me and
four kids found a spaceship buried
underground I'm pretty sure I'm a
superhero
cool pick it back up